years ago i made two videos on strange
elevators that go both horizontally and
vertically the first was in genoa italy
it's a little cabin that travels along a
tunnel which then gets loads into a
regular vertical elevator the second is
in a test tower in rottweil in germany
it uses fancy complicated locking
mechanisms and linear induction motors
but the key thing about both those
designs is they come to a complete stop
when changing direction because of how
elevators work safely and smoothly
transitioning from horizontal to
vertical just isn't possible
or at least i thought so but it turns
out that the schmidt people mover has
been doing exactly that for about 20
years
only three of these have ever actually
been installed only two of them still
exist this is the larger one at a train
station in outback germany it took me a
long time to understand how this works
and how it works safely i had to hire an
engineering consultant to look at the
original patents and break it down for
me and also with the help of producer in
germany i tracked down the inventor my
name is
machining
this cabin isn't being pulled by cables
the motor is in the cabin itself it
pulls itself along by turning a pair of
cogs up top that sit at rack rails one
on each side of the cabin so this is
basically a cargo railway a very fancy
one with anti-shape devices but a
suspended cog railway and that explains
the smooth transition to vertical at the
top the cogs just follow the rails as
they curve but how does it do this
safely and then travel vertically
without you know falling to the ground
well like the elevator in general it
does get a bit of help on the vertical
part it locks onto a carrier device and
a counterweight with safety systems that
are roughly equivalent to a regular
elevator the carrier is what you can see
start moving through the window as you
transition to vertical movement and
meanwhile down at the bottom the
counterweight sits on calibrated springs
so that as this cabin starts to transfer
to vertical the counterweight gently
lifted away from the springs and
everything balanced there is an elegant
but also quite complicated docking and
undocking mechanism up there in the roof
for the cabin the carrier the closest
analogy i can come up with is that it's
a bit like closing it up an over garage
door everything just sort of slides into
place
in the fabric
completely still wouldn't
it's a wonderful design but it's also
complicated and the alternative is to
put in an underpass or two mass-produced
elevators and a footbridge between them
because if one of those elevators breaks
down well it can be fixed by any
qualified technician using off-the-shelf
parts instead of someone who has to be
specially trained for this one rare bit
of equipment and if you have a
footbridge you probably also have stairs
so if one of those elevators breaks down
there's a backup it doesn't work for
everyone but it's better than nothing
and that also means that if you are late
for your train and physically able you
can just run up across and down the
footbridge instead of waiting for the
people mover to arrive now that said
there are advantages to this system uh
it requires much less land than a
regular footbridge does uh it doesn't
need tunneling like an underpass and if
you have heavy or bulky bags where you
don't have to haul them in and out of
multiple elevators and across the
footbridge it just takes them across for
you
[Music]
only
personal medium
i think there is a possible world in
which this design became popular and the
parts became off the shelf and
this became the standard i don't think
it's a bad invention it's very clever it
solves a specific problem
but when there are more common and more
reliable alternatives that are just a
bit more hassle to install well
not many places want to take the risk
you